people think I have knowledge no my head
is empty that's why to make it look
little substantial I have a turbine it's
totally empty always but I have Clarity
Clarity means what you see things the
way they are knowledge means what you
have fixed information about everything
if things have changed you will not see
the way it is that's as good as being
blank say people think owls are blind
it's not true their vision is far more
sensitive than yours but because of
sunlight they're blinded because it's
too much when light goes down he sees
very clearly not because he's blind
because his eyes are super sensitive
it's important that you bring Clarity to
your life not knowledge because
knowledge is conclusions that you gather
knowledge is okay when you're trying to
do something physical material in the
world but not with life need motivation
watch at top 10 on believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carl Michael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best sad Guru and my take on his
top 10 rules of success enjoy
is it true
what you thought was absolute at the age
of 12. today is not true
yes or no
are you sure that whatever you think is
this is it right now will be this is it
in another three years time of course
not you know that so you know you're
wrong
[Music]
yes sir no yes yes so you know anyway
you're wrong so why assert the wrong
things
well right now we are wrong at least
let's manage with little
more conscious if you know you're wrong
you will walk carefully isn't it hello
but you you think you're absolutely
correct then you will do stupid things
and you blunder around the world
if you know you're not seeing properly
will you walk carefully or not
if I asked you to walk through a dark
room suppose we turn off all the lights
and close it down everything pitch dark
if I ask you to walk suddenly will you
become super alert and conscious as to
how you walk
but when the lights are on
you're just going unconsciously bumping
into everybody
so if you learn to walk every moment
like there are no lights and you're
looking at everything absolutely
carefully
then what you see clearly you go through
it what you don't see see clearly you
hesitate some places you take a little
bit of chance but if you are just
confident
you will blunder through life we don't
know where you will get in and what you
will get trapped into
most people are trapped into their
professions their family situations
their social situations in such a way
they all became like
yes already I am saying
not just older people youth have become
like this
what will happen to me at the end of my
life what will happen to me at the end
of my life I'm already revealed the
secret you will die
but
sadhguru if this happens what to do if
that happens what to do all those things
will happen
it's not that everything will happen in
your life the way you like it things
will happen in the way you don't like it
it once happened Shankar and pillai got
fired from his job
simply because he asked a question
smoking or not smoke non-smoking
how can you get fired by asking such a
simple question
smoking or non-smoking he asked and he
got fired
because what he was supposed to ask was
cremation or burial
[Music]
so many times what you do thinking I am
right may be irrelevant to the situation
in which you exist
so the most important aspect of your
life is your relevant
not right
you're just relevant to the existing
situation you're relevant I am right I
am right I am right
this is confidence
you being right nobody cares all the
idiots who think they are right nobody
wants to listen to them nobody wants to
be around them isn't it
people who always think I am right I am
right you want to be around them
now the important thing is you're
relevant to the situation in which you
exist if you have to bring relevance
into your life you must extinguish your
confidence and bring Clarity rule number
two be a full-fledged human you should
not be a motivated person generally
somebody when we say someone is
motivated
it means they have an agenda of Their
Own
Life Has No Agenda it's for you to be a
full-fledged life a grasshopper is
trying to be a full-fledged grasshopper
earthworm is trying to be a full-fledged
earthworm a bird is trying to be a
full-fledged bird a tree is trying to be
a full-fledged tree a human being should
strive to become a full-fledged human
being
there's all our businesses
but each one of us start creating our
own agendas and doing all kinds of
things no no you're just a piece of life
don't take yourself too seriously
because before you and me countless
number of people have come and gone
yes or no where are they
all those people
you think they were all idiots
they were all idiots and they died is it
no they were also like you maybe they
were also officers maybe they were Kings
more than you all kinds of things
all topsoil now
this will also become top soil
just a little bit of time life is a bit
of a sparkle
how old is your sunshine
25
so 27 years ago where was he sir
so if somebody is not here we say
they're dead isn't it
27 years ago he was dead
we will give him 100 Years sir 80 years
later
he will be again dead
[Music]
yes
so 27 years ago how long was the dead
Fair
huh
[Music]
a long time
so 85 years later or 80 years later how
long will he be dead sir
very long time
so all of us will be dead for a very
long time
they're alive just for a brief amount of
time
yes very brief amount of time
we will be dead for a very long time I
want you to look at it in this
perspective how long will you be dead
you can't imagine so let us say
10 000 years to your dad or hundred
thousand years they are dead or a
million years we are dead all right
how long are you alive compared to that
very very brief what you call is life is
a brief Sparkle the only thing that you
have to do is rise and Sparkle as a
full-fledged life
when something is needed around us we
will do that naturally because when
you're doing wonderfully well you will
do what is needed isn't it
when you're miserable you will be
motivated
yes
tell me when you are very happy have you
looked at yourself how nice and
wonderful you are you're willing to do
anything for anybody Bend backwards if
necessary yes or no
when you're little frustrated
whoo
how difficult it is
so don't teach your children to become
motivated about something these are all
nonsense that's coming from the West all
those trashy self-help books motivate
yourself build confidence believe in
yourself you believed in God and
destroyed so much of this world now you
believe in yourself what will you do
rule number three learn to be alone
the Buddha was asked
is it better to walk alone
or in company
he said
it's better to walk alone than to walk
with a fool
well
that's him not me
he was quite sure that only a fool will
walk with you
so he said it's better to walk alone
than to walk with the fool
thank you
certain law in this country
says
when you want to do a short and quick
Journey Walk Alone
when you want to do a long journey walk
in company
but the important thing is
who is walking with you
not always being together is a good
thing
many times
being together can be a nuisance
so
first and foremost
unless you are a twin
even then
we come along and we go along
if one does not know
how to be by himself
or herself
then being together can be a lot of
nuisance
we are referred to as human beings
human beings means
every other creature
is what it is simply because of what he
does
but a human being can simply be
which is a unique quality of the human
being that we can simply be that we are
not compulsive action that's what it
means
our action is conscious and judicious
but generally when people get together
generally people are in compulsive
action
it can be an association where there
could be a purposeful action
or it can be a gang where there can be
more purposeful action
or it can be a crowd which can be a
compulsive action
so essentially to be human means
we have reached that point of evolution
within ourselves
that if we wish we can simply sit here
just be
we can consider
as to what action to take and what not
to take
this is definitely individual
when individuals come together
we say
it's we in
in plural
but still it is individuals who have to
come together
to be an individual means
you are not further divisible
that means you're just one
people find different ways to divide
themselves within themselves
in India with eight ten thousand years
of cultural history
we have invented various words to divide
ourselves
it's very common for people to talk in
terms of Atma paramatma Ankara this one
and that one
but every every culture has this in
their own way
when things are going right
when good things are being done if you
ask people they say yes I did it
when things don't go right when things
go wrong
then they will try to find somebody if
they don't find anybody
is always there
when they are very wonderful
of course they take pride in being how
wonderful they are
when they turn nasty they say it was my
ego
Mr ego is always a Fall Guy
so individual means
but if I'm wonderful it's me if I am
nasty it's me all of you
are you 24 hours wonderful
hello
are you 24 hours wonderful
no no sometimes wonderful sometimes
nasty sometimes beautiful sometimes ugly
it's okay
if we understand it is me who is capable
of being absolutely wonderful and it is
me who is capable of being absolutely
nasty another moment
then gradually the number of moments of
nastiness will keep on receding
if I see
what is wonderful is me what is nastiest
in India we have many words it's my
karma what can I do
now you must fix this
being an individual is very important
that means you're not further divisible
if I am wonderful it's me if I'm nasty
it's me
if I succeed it's me if I fail it's me
you have to fix this rule number four do
what you want just learn to be like God
never intervene in anything
every day in the morning
every kind of idiot will tell you what
you should do today
you just listen
just like God
marriage will work it may not work with
your profession
say yeah
you're misunderstanding this
you're trying to make this into some
kind of a value system
you're trying to make it your philosophy
I will do only what works
[Music]
well you took a oath I will do only what
works now you don't know what works
because what we what works will not come
with a oath
or a commandment what works comes with
constant observation and evolution of
who you are isn't it
hello
the same things how you made them work
how clumsily you made something work 10
years ago the same thing you may be
doing it with ease today isn't it so
or you may be doing it clumsily today
you're doing it well at one time
whichever way whichever kind of
evolution has happened
so what works
is not some kind of a formula
it is an evolution of a human being to
come to what works on all levels of life
okay
uh
uh this is like really I mean you you're
just falling out of a self-help book
no I am not a self-help book
do what works do whatever the hell you
want
what's my problem
[Music]
but what's the point of doing something
that doesn't work
hello
I am not telling you you should do only
what works do whatever the hell you want
but for your life because it's a limited
amount of time
what is the point doing something that
does not work isn't it
either it should work for you or it
should work for people around you if it
doesn't work for you and anybody around
you what is the point of doing that damn
thing
this happened
soldiers American soldiers were leaving
on duty
so
one of them told the other
you know Steve's wife
she read Three Musketeers and she
delivered a triple delivered triplets
he says oh my God my wife is reading
Birth of a Nation
what am I supposed to do
that's not how it works
so don't make this into some kind of an
ethic or a philosophy I will do only
what works
well just to see what works needs lot of
application even for the smallest damn
things isn't it
hello
to do a smallest thing
like hitting a ball or kicking a ball
straight
you know
how much it takes
somebody who can take a ball where he
wants wow the whole world is worshiping
him
just because he kicks a damn ball
yes or no
because people understand what it takes
nobody is worshiping worshiping him
because he kicks a ball because people
can see what has gone into it
isn't it so
people can see what has gone into
to be able to kick a ball the way he is
kicking what has gone into it is a life
has gone into it
so don't make philosophies and ethics
out of everything or don't tell yourself
a commandment
I will do only what works
it's a good commandment
but now you don't know what works
so
I don't know
you
you need to be conscious and apply
yourself to every damn thing
you should just learn this much
that you don't decide what is important
and what is not important also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five don't deal with
ignorance I would say uh there's
literally no human being
who is not confronted with a thought and
an emotion like that
but they managed to brush us aside it
doesn't bother them enough
the pain of not knowing doesn't tear
them that's the whole problem
they come to terms with ignorance they
make a deal with ignorance they will
build relationships where everybody will
confirm this is the best way to live
off Comfort companionship love affection
these are all things you're seeking I
know a whole lot of people have raised
human emotions to Heavens if you say
love they say Divine love if you say Joy
they say Divine Joy if you say Bliss
they say Divine Bliss
you don't need any God's help to be
joyful loving peaceful
as a human being you end out with these
qualities
so all those who deprived themselves of
that they either seek
God or they settle for a dog
yeah usually
because
they want a unconditional love this is a
demand
because the nature of Love is such that
it's like a flower if you don't watch it
for two minutes It'll fall
it'll wither and fall right there
either you want to
let it fall
or you have to nourish it every moment
or you have to concretize it that means
you take a picture and keep it on your
phone screen
or you institutionalize it with marriage
or this or that
so essentially
well I'm I'm not against any institution
because institutions are needed in the
world to operate otherwise there will be
chaos
that is a different thing but you cannot
institutionalize Joy or peace like right
now we think United Nations is the
institution for peace no no you cannot
institutionalize peace
you cannot institutionalize Joy you
cannot institutionalize love or anything
for that matter institutions are
functional instruments in a given
Society I have utmost respect for them
because without it people a whole lot of
people wouldn't know how to live
you need institutions there is a
government there is a democratic process
there are a variety of things all right
there are courts there are parliaments
well ninety percent of the time some
nonsense may be happening there but
still these institutions are important
because without that there will be total
chaos
so I'm not talking against institutions
but institutionalizing things that
happen within a human being
is a silly effort rule number six make
the most of your life in the yoga
culture
first eight years
or actually eight and a half years
is considered childhood
so these are not counted though
balavastha is up to 12. it's the eight
and a half years where you're a real
child you know it from your own
experience after you're eight and a half
only your parents thought you were a
child but you were secretly many things
yes
adults think that you are a child but
you know you are not one
because your childhood in many ways ends
at eight and a half
so if you take two side solar Cycles
which is uh
24 years or little less than that
and add eight and a half years to it
it will become
32 and 3 4 or something like this
32 years in seven months are somewhere
there
exact calculations we can make but it's
nearly 33 years
so when these two cycles end
living that when it ends
it is a possibility
this is a time when your life could take
on a different level of propulsion
if you have prepared yourself well
either with education or some skill or
yoga or
inner dimensions of your life if you
have prepared yourself on any of these
things that is the time when it can
Propel or that is the time when it can
start crashing
you know in the western societies they
talk about mid-life crisis
it usually starts around 33 34 years of
age
suddenly people don't know what to do
with themselves
life getting meaningless or those who
are successful they find
traction and suddenly they explode into
different levels of success or
well-being
all this can happen
because
within the system it has completed a
certain cycle either it can take off or
it can crash rule number seven expand
your horizons let one human being
honestly say
when you are with your most loving
parents however doting and wonderful
they were to you
that you never felt this is not where
you want to be
that is a dishonest human being
because
love gets tedious
somebody's fondness gets very tedious
Comfort gets tedious
because the nature of life is it wants
to constantly expand
if there is no room for expansion it
doesn't matter you are kept in a uh
whatever I won't use because everybody
uses the word Golden Palace I think
Golden Palace is totally anesthetic in
my uh
my visual perception I hate Golden
Palace but whatever is the most
wonderful Palace
or as you say Shangri-La whatever
you it will get tedious
all the heaven-bound people
they don't know how bored they will be
within three days in that place of
goodness
so I am saying it doesn't matter it's
not because there's something wrong with
your parents
they may be most wonderful people
but
the very nature of a human being is such
only if you are a pet animal if you have
reduced yourself to that you're just
happy
with the meals that you're getting and
somebody is funneling you once in a way
and you're happy with that
for that you must be a pet animal you
should not be born as a human being once
you're born as a human being it is
natural wanting to break
barriers so when you're young as a child
or a teenager you think barriers means
they're all physical before you
understand the barriers are not really
physical whether you build your own
house or you live in your parents house
or you live in a slave master's house
the house and walls are not the barrier
it is all within us before you realize
that or how soon you realize that will
lead to either transformation or
frustration rule number eight learn to
rest you can simply sit
if you learn to simplicit
you will become tremendously intense
right now your energy is simply expanded
by doing unnecessary
endless activity
when you have so much
mental diarrhea how can you have energy
suppose you have diarrhea do you see how
weak you feel yes or no right now this
mental diarrhea that's why people have
no energy
they want to just eat and sleep all the
time because mental diarrhea it's very
exhausting
if you have physical diarrhea you know
how exhausting it is
yes
this is also equally exhausting
people are sleeping eight hours ten
hours a day
not because they are working so much or
their body is in such a bad state
it's just mental diarrhea
if you stop the mental diarrhea there's
enough energy to make this very very
intense
now how do I stop mental diarrhea
if you have diarrhea physical diarrhea
what is the first thing to do
huh what
yes run to the toilet I know that
I'm saying yeah as a as a corrective
measure what is the first thing you do
no as a corrective measure what is the
first thing you do
first thing is stop eating right
I should know
but diarrhea means in some way we've
eaten something that the body doesn't
want
it's trying to throw it out
yes
you've taken something inside which the
body doesn't like it wants to throw it
out
first thing is
[Music]
stay away from food for some time
you eat bad food and then try to stop
diarrhea it's not going to work
so similarly bad food for the mind is
just this
you have gotten identified with things
that you are not
the moment you get identified with
things that you are not
mental diarrhea is inevitable
it's bad food for the mind now it will
run endlessly do what you want
you do any damn meditation you say Shiva
Rama it's not going to stop
it's not stopped isn't it
because bad food is being eaten every
day you're getting identified with more
and more things and you want to stop
your mind
you do whatever kind of circus
it is not going to stop
if you disidentify with everything
if you understand what is you and what
is not you
if you keep a little distance from that
mind will become still
if you want you can use it otherwise you
can keep it
now my hand is there if I want I can
move it otherwise I can keep it this is
a useful hand suppose it starts jumping
like this
you clearly know
there is some kind of an ailment isn't
it
yes or no
so if hand is jumping you know it's an
ailment if mind is jumping is it an
ailment or no
oh
the element has come because continuous
wrong diet
you tell your mind
that I am this I am this I am that I am
that
it's having the idea
you stop giving it wrong food
if you clearly see what even if you do
not know what is me at least you know
what is not me isn't it
this much you do
tonight before you go to bed
sit on your bed
and sit down and discount everything
that is not you
this house in Europe in which you're
living is this me
no
this loving parent or mother father wife
or husband or child
they're wonderful but is this me
no
no these nice clothes I'm wearing is
this me no
now my body I like it but is this me no
now I am having so many thoughts is this
me no
now I'm having wonderful emotions is
this me no
like this everything that's not you
before you sleep keep it down and go to
bed
tomorrow morning you will wake up
considerably more intense than today
rule number nine commit to success this
happened in your school maybe later in
your University later in your work it's
happening to people maybe not everyone
but a whole lot of people
their commitment to success is weak
they want to succeed they will take
three steps then something little
interesting happens here they will go
away here they'll go away there they'll
go away there hey I want to live
their commitment to success is weak
uh either situations around them in some
way you know situations can impede you
from doing what you're doing very easily
many times it happens to everyone
but when this happens people weaken
their commitment for their success
maybe physically they'll feel a little
weak
they will weaken their commitment to
success maybe their emotions loss around
a little bit
they will weaken their commitment to
success
this is very important right now
however long it takes this virus
you must come out of this successfully
that means you will stay alive that's an
important part
[Music]
and
Staying Alive
should not be slackened no matter what
happened somebody very dear to us passed
away all the more important we must live
[Music]
people around us are all sick all the
more important we are healthy to take
care of the people around us
so our commitment to success should not
weaken because there is social drama
going on or physiological drama or
psychological drama whatever happens
your commitment to success should not
weaken that is what get you across so
many lines in our life so many barriers
in our life
so what does success look like
what does it take
you must understand
those who made any significant
achievements in their life
ah they did not
you know
I don't want to take any personal
examples of anybody I'm trying to avoid
obvious things that are coming to my
mind well
[Music]
you know I know family and friends
who always have their breakfast on time
and after breakfast of course they must
have coffee
after coffee of course they must light
up a cigarette and sit there nicely
because they're trying to
become peaceful
[Music]
and then they will go to work
come back home exactly on time for lunch
eat lunch
rest for one or two hours sleep
then evening have one tea and then smoke
and then again go to work
and eight eight o'clock 8 30 they're
back home for dinner and then maybe
other things drink and this and that and
whatever
[Music]
well that's their priority
it's fine I'm not complaining it should
not be that way
but those who have been very successful
either in music sport art business
spiritual process doesn't matter what
those people
never know when they ate when they slept
when they got afternoon rest I have not
seen such a thing in my life
so uh
those who are committed to being
successful with whatever they are doing
one important aspect of their life is
they are not settling down wherever it's
a bit comfortable
because Comfort will happen when they
lower you to in the grave very
comfortable you are you know Angel
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is choose your
priorities hello
so just do this one thing stop
discriminating what is important what is
not important
if you pay the same level of absolute
attention to every damn thing you will
see
that what is the right thing to do is a
very natural process
but you have already decided what is
important what is not important how will
you evolve what is the right thing to do
half the world is already been given up
because it's not important
you are paying attention only you even
look at somebody properly only if they
are of something to you
no I looked at everybody absolutely
every life every damn thing every Pebble
every moment that was happening in the
earth in the atmosphere everything not
as a study simply because I had eyes
and I had an attention span I paid
attention to everything today they are
saying this is something phenomenal I
was just laughing and saying see I just
wandered aimlessly everybody thought I
am just a vagabond but now this aimless
wandering has is paying off in a huge
way foreign
because it doesn't matter what the hell
you're doing small things are big things
if you are absolutely involved
absolutely
you will see you will know what's the
right thing to do
you trying to live here without
involvement this is why you have morals
you have ideals you have ideologies you
have values you have ethics you have
Commandments
because you are trying to live here
without involvement
you want ready-made formula what is the
right thing to do thou shall not thou
shall not thou shall not did the world
get fixed I'm asking
every goddamn school-going children
knows what is the right thing to do has
it worked
it's not worked because you think there
is a substitute for involvement
there is no substitute for involvement
where there is no involvement there will
be no life it so don't try to make
formulas
or ideals or ideologies out of life all
life takes is absolute involvement
unbridled involvement not distinguishing
who is who what is what just absolutely
involved with everything that you're in
touch with right now
if you do this one thing
well according to your level of
intelligence
and
you know nature also should yield
foreign
with all this you will know what is the
best thing to do given your perspective
of course
see right now if you bring a man of
certain capability
he may do something in a given situation
that's not the right thing to do for you
isn't it
you must know what is the right thing
for you to do in a given situation you
won't be able to do what he does
you must be able to do what you can do
to the best of your ability that is the
right thing to do in your life
you don't try to do like somebody else
so that will be the problem the moment
you decide what is the right thing to do
now
there is no ready-made solution
involvement
there is no substitute for environment
where there is no involvement there is
no life
don't utter the word freedom because
freedom is a consequence it's something
that you have to earn it doesn't come as
a philosophy in 60s we thought it's a
philosophy
if you live responsibly you will see
Freedom will come when I say responsibly
not in the sense of civic responsibility
if you retain your ability to respond to
life
without any prejudice
without any restriction you will see you
will become free
your ability to respond if it is
unlimited it is freedom why does one
person need a
well by prescription these days eight
hours is it seven seventy eight hours
seven hours sleep okay seven hours
and why another person can do with half
of that
see one thing is
as we already went through the very
physical body that you carry is just the
food that you've eaten isn't it
you are looking at Food only as protein
vitamin mineral like this
but we're talking about a food chain
that means
they're all different kinds of lives
what we consume is another form of life
every animal consumes another form of
life this is the way the food cycle is
created
so in what condition that life is will
determine
in what condition your life is in many
ways
so your food appears in front of me if I
just look at it people have prepared it
with elaborate care if I just look at it
as you know
this is Guru this girl this lady has
brought it she's a very good cook she's
very tasty
I just look it in a channel
simply because it's not alive enough for
me it may be tasty but it's not alive
enough for me
if it's not alive enough I will not
consume if you're just conscious of this
one thing
you will see your sleep quota will go
down
another thing is most people are eating
at least 50 percent 50 means hundred
percent more than what they need to eat
yes you you will do one thing as an
experiment just try this whatever you're
eating cut it down by 50 percent
if you're eating let's say uh two
kilograms of food cut it down to one
kilogram and eat variety of foods you
will see you will neither drop weight
nor will you become weak nor will you
become less energetic only thing that
will happen is your sleep quota will go
down
because you are putting so much food to
generate the same same amount of energy
you're eating more by compulsion of
liking the taste or simply by compulsion
of filling yourself up now the body has
to press process so much food to create
so much energy this extra processing is
taking a toll on the system the amount
of impurities that are there in the food
will also determine how how much inertia
you generate in the body let's
understand it this way in terms of
physical terms what sleep means is
inertia right now your Dynamic this is
life inertia said sin
when inertia goes beyond a certain point
that's death
but sleep is a certain kind of death but
it is offering you rest
so restfulness is very important
what is being restful means is
if you sit here if you're a total ease
you will see the body is naturally
restful if you have you noticed on a
particular day you are very happy on
that day you don't need much sleep or
food have you noticed this
that's all you have to do
if you remain very joyful every moment
of your life the food will come down
sleep will come down naturally I don't
know I never looked at Life as a series
of mistakes learning from that I don't
look at life like that
well
have you done made some dumb decisions
here and there of course but
uh
I wouldn't see them as mistakes I just
see them as part of growing up and
becoming more mature because
Enlightenment is one thing you see
things clearly but still operating in
the world you need wisdom wisdom you
have to earn it with experience there is
simply no other way for that today it
has become fashionable with all these
management gurus and all saying You must
learn from your mistake you must learn
mistakes that means you must keep on
doing mistakes I don't believe that you
must learn from your mistakes I would
rather live a life where I don't do any
mistakes
because life is so brief you do a bunch
of mistakes and then you will learn and
where will you use it in the grave
yeah yes
it means that we can learn from other
people's experience from history we can
learn we don't have to do all those
things once again and especially you are
from the aviation state if you are
trying Aviation or if you're trying
skydiving or something if you don't do
things right the first time well that
will be the last time there are many
aspects to this fundamentally if you
keep your life energies very exuberant
now you will see the slip quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be over lead
largely in the ashram everybody young
people also eat only two meals a day 10
in the morning seven in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world and we are seven days 365 days we
don't know what's a vacation because we
are enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so they never go on a vacation there is
no break there's no Sunday Monday
nonsense nothing every day something is
happening endlessly
but you will see people are very
energetic healthy sleep is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things a certain
amount of energy and a certain amount of
time
when it comes to time it is ticking away
for all of us at the same Pace plot
doesn't run slowly for me faster for you
there's no such thing
whether you are busy you are lazy you're
sleeping you're doing useful things or
useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there's no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity what somebody does in
10 years you may do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become Static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day how long do you want
to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody I'm going to
die
for yourself how long do I want to die
in a day eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you did
in 24 hours eight hours your day means
one third of your life dead another four
hours goes into eating sleeping eating
toilet bath this that where is the time
to live I'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time
perception happens to you in five
different dimensions seeing hearing
smelling tasting touching this is how
you're perceiving life this data data
has gathered within you only because
this data has gathered within you now
you are able to walk on a round Planet
which spins it's not a small thing
it is not a small thing that you are
able to walk on a spinning round ball
because all this data has gathered
through five senses it is not
intellectual information but it is a
perceptional information if this
information is not there you won't be
able to walk actually
you will not be able to walk straight
this is what is happening for people
when some people lose their memory and
things like that suddenly they become
unstable in their body because some of
the data is gotten disconnected with
their system so this data that you
perceive is most important that's what a
child is all the time drinking up
everything you see how the child is
looking at everything because he wants
to drink up as much data as possible
because instinctively he knows without
the data he will not be able to function
so how attentive you are how attentive
your eyes are how at interview your ears
nose tongue and touch is accordingly you
have that much you know that much usable
information so why one person is more
efficient well you are an athlete why
one person is able to catch a damn ball
another person can't catch the damn
thing why is it because that level of
attention of exactly how that ball will
be behave how you can anticipate where
it will go this is not there
intellectually suppose you have a PhD in
football you think you can play football
uh uh if you have a PhD no I think you
need to experience it as well if you
just study it only yeah
oh that is that is
exception
you're watching exactly how a ball moves
you may not be thinking the physics of
it but you're watching it and perceiving
it because of that perception you know
something that you cannot know by
reading 100 books about it the notion of
the difference between pain and
suffering I thought was very useful
it's a pain is physiological it's there
because no pain most people would not
even know how to protect themselves
see just because there's no pain and
they see what all you have done to it
isn't it see there's no pain in this so
that's why you took it off if there's no
pain in your nose
maybe you would have taken it off right
because the many advantages you will
take in about 22 percent extra oxygen if
you just remove this one thing
contraption
[Laughter]
wherever there is no pain people are
messing with it like crazy isn't it they
call this hairstyle they call it so many
things yeah
Suppose there was no pain in the entire
body in Los Angeles people would pull
out their stomach bag and
you think they wouldn't do it no they
probably would
only pain is helping them to preserve
themselves isn't it so pain is good
there's no physiological pain most
people would not know I hear in United
States there's one group they call
themselves something I forget that word
they're actually cutting their fingers
off their hands off on the video
wow they're posting it online
there's a group like that whoa can you
imagine this no in spite of so much pain
if there was no pain almost everybody
would have cut themselves off into in
the name of fashion they would have cut
themselves into ribbons wow
so pain is a good thing physically
because that is your
preservation self-preservation mechanism
but suffering is something that you do
in your mind
so pain that happens in your body you
take it in your mind and multiply it a
thousand times or a million times
depending on how capable you are or how
stupid you are and suffer it a million
times over
right now most human beings are like
this what happened 10 years ago they can
still suffer
what may happen day after tomorrow they
already suffer
they are not suffering life they think
they are suffering life they are not
suffering life they are suffering the
two most fantastic faculties that human
beings alone have a vivid sense of
memory and a fantastic sense of
imagination don't pursue enlightenment
you cannot pursue enlightenment
how can you pursue something that you do
not know
if you pursue something you will pursue
only what you know
what is the point pursuing something
that you already know
what is the point in running after
something that you already know
so if you have to step into something
that you do not know
the only thing is just to keep walking
keep a steady Direction and keep walking
maybe it's the wrong direction it
doesn't matter just keep working after
all planet is round
inevitably
if you keep walking and keep straight
walking not round and round
if you just keep straight walking
you will inevitably get somewhere
nobody can take it away from you
you know
if you have a dog at home you would know
this if you just tickle him in the tail
he will go
chasing his own tail
okay A lot of people are doing that
[Music]
they don't tell they're chasing
even Enlightenment is their own Tale
nobody told you there is such a thing
but
definitely you can see
from one person to another person
one person seems to be little better off
simply the way they are not because of
their money not because of their wealth
not because of their qualifications
simply the way they sit and stand
somebody seems to be better off than
somebody else
yes or no
so there is room and scope for
improvement
relentlessly improve let's see where it
gets you
but if you have fancy ideas of what is
enlightenment
then you will chase that silly idea
and that idea is never enlightenment
because it's your idea something will
get you money something will get you
comfort that's not the point what you
choose to do will it give you a life
when I say give it give you a life are
you just trying to make a living or are
you trying to make a life out of this
it's important
making a living is not an issue a worm a
insect a bird an animal all of them are
making their life making a living isn't
it so
that even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not an issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
I want to live is not a problem I want
to live like you this is a problem
so it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life you must make
sure you make a wonderful life out of
this in your book you talk about
something I thought was so interesting
to set the faucet to a certain drip rate
and do nothing but focus on the dripping
of the fossa for like seven minutes or
something but the idea is to pay
attention to something which has no
relevance to you
say people are have divided the universe
this is important this is not important
this person is important for me this
person is not important this is
important for me that's not important
for me you divided the universe you will
never know anything this way
indiscriminate Focus indiscriminate
attention I am not attending to you
because you are somebody with a cobra in
your heart all right
it doesn't matter who I speak to who I
am with I'm the same way
indiscriminate
only when your attention and involvement
is indiscriminate does the universe open
up to you
you have discriminated naturally you
close you know people come to me and say
Sad Guru I want to walk the spiritual
path
I say okay
be here for three days let's see what we
can do day after tomorrow my uncle's
daughter's birthday I have to go
oh you want to get enlightened
and Day After Tomorrow uncle's
daughter's birthday also all right
we got one and a half days
you do one thing you do this this and
this as I said group but I don't like
this
all right I'll give them a small piece
of paper
and say okay write down things that you
like we'll do only do that
you won't believe it in this entire
universe most people like only three or
four things
when you are so constipated in your head
that you lack only three or four people
or three or four things in your life how
do you want to open up to the existence
because life is happening because of its
openness
this is a fundamental difference between
death and life is people are thinking
it's just breath all right on one level
that is also openness whether you allow
this to happen or you don't allow it to
happen
whether you did it consciously or
unconsciously but it's happening isn't
it openness is on every subatomic
particle is in communication with
everything that's why this is going on
breath is happening so much is happening
in connection with everything it is only
in openness you're alive
as you close doors you are dying in
installments
dying in installments is torture
see
life is fantastic if you're alive and
fully alive
if you're dead it's good at least the
neighbors may think so
this may sound very not so compassionate
but I'm saying everybody dies you and me
will die all right
if you're dead it's the game is over
but if you're half dead oh
this is endless torture to yourself when
you are being tortured of course you
will share it with everybody else this
happened at the Cincinnati airport in
Ohio United States people had lined up
to check in at the airline ticket booth
one man just skipped the line and came
straight in the front and thrust his
ticket
the lady at the counter she said sir
there is a line
he said no no I'm in a hurry
she said everybody's in a hurry you're
on the same plane
please stand in the line
then he said do you know who I am
she looked at him promptly picked up the
microphone and said there is a man here
who does not know who he is can somebody
help him
so
who am I
is not a question that you ask somebody
it's a question that you ask yourself
make it more and more profound
unfortunately
in many ways not just in the way that I
said now in many different ways I would
say
70 of illnesses on the planet all kinds
are self-created even if you get an
infection there is a way if you keep
yourself in a certain way physically and
mentally
the virus in the bacteria will not work
the same way as it works upon somebody
else
if you set yourself like this
no matter what's happening
anyway I have to go and do this this and
this there's no break from that
the last 29 years
I have not been able to cancel one
program because I'm running temperature
I got a cold I got this I got that
it doesn't matter what's happening what
you have to do you anyway have to do you
can't turn back on that
either out of your commitment or you
have a boss like that
yes one or one way or the other if it
happens
then you will see
you will not at all fall sick so often
because if you have temperature
you still have to go if it's summer you
still go right
now a lot of people don't go it's a
little hot outside they don't go and
work little cold outside they don't go
and work a little raining they won't go
on work a snowflake they will not go on
work
this is just weather
so for every change in weather
if you have the comfort of covering
yourself in a blanket and lying down
once you create that your body will
learn to fall sick as often as possible
if you just keep it this way it doesn't
matter
what it is anyway I have to go and do
what I have to do you will see your body
will just bounce back
as quickly as possible even if it gets
the worst kind of infections
so you just have to set the necessary
conditions for health necessary in
incentives for health both for yourself
and your children if you have them
do not set incentives for sickness
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this one but the quality of
your life is essentially determined by
how you carry this one
yes or no
this moment
what kind of clothes you're wearing what
kind of card you parked outside what
kind of home you live in does not
determine the quality of your life this
moment how joyful are you feeling within
yourself determines the quality of your
life isn't it so
nothing has been done about it you think
it'll happen in consequence
and you're setting impossible goals for
your happiness if I have to be happy my
wife should be like this my husband
should be like that my children should
be like this the world should become
some other way
well these are impossible conditions
you're setting for your happiness and
peacefulness
now that you have compromised yourself
to peace
why I'm saying compromise yourself to
pieces
because a lot of people have given up
aspirations for being ecstatic or
Blissful if I'm just peaceful it's
enough even the so-called spiritual
leaders are going about and saying peace
is the highest goal in your life
peace is not the highest goal in your
life if you want to enjoy your lunch
today you must be peaceful
this one
if you're not even peaceful there is
nothing in your life that you can do in
a worthwhile way
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind
to be peaceful means
that your system is at ease you know how
to conduct your mind you know how to
conduct your emotions your body and your
energies you are peaceful
it is not a rocket technology
it is the most basic thing you have a
dog at home you give him his food he
sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic but peacefully many
times they're ecstatic also
yes
if your dog is able to sit please oh he
doesn't have to run my industry
that's not the point he's got his own
stuff going
[Music]
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing it's
got something to do with the internal
systems as to how they're functioning
essentially it means either neither your
body nor your mind or your Chemistry nor
your emotions nor energy or taking
instructions from you they're doing
their own thing
once your machine is not in your control
being peaceful is impossible I'll tell
you you get into your car and now you go
there and you want to turn this way you
do this to the steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you no anxiety is natural isn't it
this is what has happened to your
vehicle it's out of control
you've never done anything to find out
where the steering wheel is first of all
this is not that simple as a car this is
a super super computer now the problem
is most people have not even bothered to
find the keyboard
they think if they do this somehow it
will work
if you make when you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine if you do
not conduct it properly it will cause
many problems to you
by accident it's working I want you to
know this this is made this way if you
hold your hands like this it'll breathe
one way if you just turn it around the
very way you breathe the breathing
pattern itself changes in your lungs you
can try it if you want when you have the
time this way this way I am saying
everything that you do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine
it's more than a touch screen if you
just wish it it will happen
when you have such a sensitive and
sophisticated machine and you are
operating like a blacksmith
then being peaceful seems to be
difficult
peace is not the highest goal in your
life it is the most fundamental
requirement don't ever set peace as the
highest goal if you do that you will
only rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life isn't it if you want
to do anything sensibly in your life
if you want to do conduct any situation
in your life sensibly to be peaceful and
happy is fundamental of all the pieces
of engineering on this planet
of many pieces of engineering a tree is
a fantastic engineering even a mountain
is fantastic engineering because it
stood there for a million years that
means it must be good engineering isn't
it yes something that stands there for a
million years must be well engineered
of all this the most sophisticated piece
of engineering is human mechanism
isn't it so
hello
most sophisticated of all the pieces of
engineering
now because it's a sophisticated piece
of engineering
it needs a certain level of attention
otherwise you don't figure it
now that we gave you such a highly
you know I take piece of engineering I
am asking you did you read the users
menu
I I think there is no user manual or no
how can I make such a fantastic piece of
engineering without a user's manual
maybe it doesn't come with a booklet
attached to your neck when you were born
thank you
but indications must be there isn't it
how to use it
huh is it true
somebody who's an athlete or a gymnast
or someone else like that learns to use
their body then a whole lot of other
people
yes obviously at least one aspect of the
physical engineering of the body
they seem to have read the user's manual
about the physical aspects
is it true certain people are able to
use their mind better than others
maybe they read another part of the
user's manual
so now uh With This Heart manual and the
Brain menu
see the problem is most people are
prejudiced against the brain
this is a question or always comes to me
sadhguru I want to meditate but thoughts
are coming
the common question everywhere
I asked them see I'll make you meditate
we will stop the liver we'll stop the
kidney we'll stop the heart we'll stop
everything okay
so you want the liver to function when
you're meditating
you wonder kidneys to function you want
even the spleen to function you want the
heart to function but you don't want
your brain to function for some reason
this is simply because
brain is a new equipment that you got in
the evolutionary process
this level of cerebral development
happened more recently compared to the
other systems if you could open any
mammal they all have all these parts
isn't it every part that you have here
all of them have
even if you open a frog
most of you your biology Department
things
even if we open a frog almost everything
that you have he also has isn't it
it is only the big difference is only
the cerebral development which is a more
recent happening
because it's a more recent happening
most people have not figured how to
handle it
so use this manual is very important you
don't read a user's manual
just before you discard the machine you
read it in the first few days isn't it
hello
if you buy a phone do you want to read
the user's manual in the first three
days or after three years when you're
throwing it away
it was three days isn't it so knowing
how this functions is very important
never did ever
heart generate any thought or intention
well when you looked at the young girl
heartbeat
more that doesn't mean it's saying
anything it's just trying to compensate
for the other levels of excitement
that's happening you thought one time I
thought this was so interesting about
how every time you get a belief it's
like a conclusion and every conclusion
is a death unto itself and it's like
shutting a door on something yes
otherwise see you just see
you look at your own picture when you're
five years of age it's like this
slowly it's becoming like this what is
it you're dying in installments
the more conclusions you make the less
alive you become this all that's
happened to people they call this
knowledge
this is not knowledge this is just
conclusions that you're drawing about
everything
see with all this scientific exploration
the fact is that even today we do not
know one single atom in its entirety we
know how to use them we know how to use
everything on this planet but we don't
know a damn thing about anything
over 90 percent or 99 of an atom is
empty we don't know what that emptiness
contains over 99 of the cosmos is empty
we don't know what that is
so this is like I give you a million
piece jigsaw
but you found in your hands you have
only three of them with this three you
make a picture and you're euphoric that
you made a picture
well I'm sorry
there are million pieces to this
has anybody gathered all the pieces no
then don't make a picture when it comes
to what you want to do
uh
you must think clearly it's very
important
thinking clearly means the question is
not about what will get me this what
will get me that
are you is your life precious to you all
of you I'm asking your life is it
precious to you so before you invest
this life
into something
you must look whether today if I invest
my life into this after 25 years will it
still mean a lot to me
after 50 years will it still mean a lot
to me at the end of my life you turn
back under a look will I be proud of
this or will I be ashamed of what I am
doing right now it doesn't matter what
other people say you should not do
anything that you
that it doesn't matter people say so
many things
everybody has opinion it's their
business
but you don't do something that you will
feel ashamed of isn't it
then you go turning against yourself
somebody turns against you you can leave
them and go somewhere else
if you turn against yourself you will
have to live with it forever
so this is all you have to look at it
somebody something will get you money
something will get you comfort that's
not the point what you choose to do will
it give you a life when I say give it
give you a life are you just trying to
make a living or are you trying to make
a life out of this is important
making a living is not an issue a worm a
insect a bird an animal all of them are
making their life making a living isn't
it so
that even making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living
so making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue
earning your food is not a issue making
a living is not an issue only problem is
you want to live like somebody else
that's an endless problem
I want to live is not a problem I want
to live like you this is a problem
so it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life you must make
sure you make a wonderful life out of
this I can show you thousands of people
around me today
when they came
they thought they won't do anything
significant half of them not half 70
percent of them are dropouts from
schools and colleges and everything
but you will see after a few years of
sadhana suddenly they are functioning in
ways that you won't believe possible
recently we had a business uh you know
event called Insight where over 200 CEOs
from across the world are coming and
participating
all of them Wonder
why our organizations don't run as
smoothly and efficiently as yours
I said that's because I all have all
dropouts who are no good for anything
they have devotion in their heart they
are devoted to what they're doing that's
all
because they're absolutely devoted to
what they are doing they may not be mbas
they may not be from iits and Iams
they're simple people but because
they're absolutely devoted they do
wonderful things if you focus whatever
you're doing right now it doesn't matter
what it is
how simple an act you're doing right now
it doesn't matter if you're absolutely
devoted to that that you're doing right
now
depending upon various aspects things
will unfold
but
because of Western influences we become
too goal oriented
goal oriented means
we are interested in the consequence but
we are not interested in the process
if you are not interested in the process
you should not be an artist
yes
process is an end in itself
if you are absolutely devoted to the
process
depending upon various aspects something
will come out
but now we are interested in the
consequence
not in the process this
goal-orientedness I want to get there I
want to get there where the hell do you
want to get
no I want to win the race
see if you treat Life as a race
if you have to win it you have to get to
the Finish Line soon isn't it
you want to
hello
if you get to the Finish Line ahead of
all these people you won the race
you know what the finish line is
we'll be negotiating where to bury you
see as we sit here this is my body that
is your body do what you want these two
things will not become one
this is my mind that is your mind do
what you want these things will not
become one they may overlap on some
issues and we may feel that we are one
with each other but my mind is my mind
your mind is your mind isn't it
but there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living Cosmos
you captured a little bit I captured a
little bit
that's about it but now we think this is
my life and that is your life there is
no such thing this is a living cop
Cosmos you've blown a small bubble
somebody might have blown a little
bigger bubble
did you blow snow bubbles when you were
young oh yeah you still do yes
so when you blow so bubbles
somebody had this big bubble somebody
else had that big bubble oh went on
saying this is my bubble this is your
bubble but poop it went
once it goes poop
you did not say this is Meyer and this
is your air
similarly there is no such thing as my
life and your life
there is just a living Cosmos
if you capture more life
then you will see you have more grace
the depth Dimension and scope of your
life is determined by how much life you
capture within you it doesn't matter
what kind of body you have what kind of
intelligence you have if you have not
captured substantial life within you you
will live a small life that's how it is
how do you do this there are systematic
ways of approaching this or simply by
involvement and exuberance by commitment
people may capture a larger life
by absolutely being committed to
something focused on something somebody
May capture a certain amount of life
which is more than what is considered
normal there is thought and there is
emotion
people think these two things are saying
different things they are not saying
different things the way you think is
the way you emote isn't it so
right now if I think oh she's the most
wonderful person on the planet
I just have to think
then my emotions become sweet towards
her
now I think she's the most horrible
creature on the planet
now my emotions become nasty yes or no
I cannot think she's horrible and have
Sweet Emotions
I cannot think she's wonderful and have
nasty emotions isn't it so but today I
thought she is the most wonderful person
and my sweetness was flowing
suddenly she did something tomorrow that
I don't like I think she's horrible
thought is agile it changes Direction
Just Like That Emotion is little sappy
it takes time to turn around
so that period you struggle as if there
are two dimensions of
thing happening because thought is
saying one thing emotion is still going
sweet because it takes time to become
nasty
everybody struggles but it catches up or
no after some time hello
today you thought she's wonderful
sweetness was flowing tomorrow she did
something you don't like you thought
she's horrible man the thought is
clearly saying she's horrible but
emotions are struggling because they
can't turn quickly they take time to
turn but after a week or 10 days or two
months depending on how deeply you're
engaged
thank you
after some time emotion catches up with
the thought emotion also says yes she's
not horrible so well let's be nasty to
her
so they are not speaking the different
languages one is agile another is little
slow in his corners
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see the
one-on-one I did about Karma with sad
Guru check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there this is
like banging your head on a wall which
is not going to break anyway it's your
head which will break what you can
change you do not change what you can
craft you do not do it because all your
energy goes into